[Music]
nintendo has announced a bunch of Fire
Emblem news and we've learned about a
handful of titles for Nintendo switched
the 3ds and mobile devices I'm Matt and
this gamespot news update is running up
all the information from Nintendo's Fire
Emblem live streamers the first thing
announced was a new game for the 3ds
called Fire Emblem echoes shadows of
Valencia it appears to be a reimagining
of the second game in the series Fire
Emblem Gaiden and features a world map
you can navigate in 3d areas you can
explore combat however still seems to
resemble what we've come to know from
the other Fire Emblem games on 3ds
shadows of Valencia launches on May
nineteenth alongside to amoeba figures
of protagonists elm and celica next up
was the announcement of a new Fire
Emblem game for the switch we didn't get
a look or any details about the new game
but we do know it's coming in 2018
however we did get a peek at another
game for the nintendo switch Fire Emblem
warriors got its first trailer and it
looks a lot like Hyrule warriors but
with Fire Emblem characters it's set to
release this fall for switch and new 3ds
systems
and last but not least we got our first
look at the free to play fire emblem
game from mobile devices Fire Emblem
heroes features gameplay similar to
other games in the series but you'll be
summoning classic characters using orbs
that yes you can buy with real money it
launches on Android and iOS devices on
februari second we'll keep you updated
as more news about all these titles as
announced so for that and much more stay
tuned to gamespot